ADAM MARTIN: And so I wanted
to start today's lecture
by continuing what
we were talking
about in the last lecture.
So I'm just going to
hide this real quick.
And so we're talking about the
fruit fly and the white gene
and the white mutant, which
results in white-eyed flies.
And we talked about how if you
take females that have red eyes
and cross them to males,
the white-eyed male,
then 100% of the progeny has
red eyes in the F1 generation.
And so I asked you
guys, would you
get the same results if you
did the reciprocal cross?
So what if we took
white-eyed females
and mated them to
red-eyed males?
So what about this?
Actually, I'm going to
move this over to over
here so that maybe
it's more visible.
So what if we have
white-eyed females
and crossed this
to red-eyed males?
So let's unpack this sort
of a little bit at a time.
So what's the genotype of
these white-eyed females here?
Miles?
AUDIENCE: So if you designate
the eye gene as the letter A,
a female would be X
lowercase a, X lowercase a.
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
So Miles is exactly right.
So the dominant
phenotype is red eyes,
because the gene encodes
for an enzyme that's
important for the production
of the red pigment.
And so X lowercase a here would
be a recessive mutant that
lacks the pigment.
And because it's a
recessive allele--
because you need only
one copy of this gene
to produce the pigment.
So the recessive allele
results in the white phenotype.
Therefore, this has to
be homozygous recessive.
How about this red-eyed male?
Yeah, Ory?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you have
a Y and then an X capital A?
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
So this would be this
phenotype, right,
where capital A is the
gene that produces--
is a normal functioning gene
that produces the pigment.
So then in your F1
here, are you going
to see something similar to
this or something different?
AUDIENCE: Something different.
ADAM MARTIN: Different, great.
Who said different?
Javier?
Do you want to propose
what you might see?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
For the males, they're
going to inherit the Y
gene from the father
and the [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
So the males are going to
get the Y from the father,
and they're going to get
one X from their mother.
So all the males are going
to be of this genotype
here, which means they're
going to have what color eye?
Javier is exactly right.
That means they're going
to have white eyes.
So all the males
will have white eyes.
And what about the females?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Red eyes.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
So Ory is saying the males are
going to get red eyes, right,
because they're--
or the females are going to
have red eyes, because they're
going to get the X chromosome
from their father, which
has the dominant gene that
produces the red pigment.
So all the females are
going to be heterozygous,
but have a functional
copy of this gene.
So all of the females
will have red eyes.
OK, does everyone see how--
now, how would this compare with
Mendel's crosses and pea color?
Would there be a difference
in Mendel's crosses
if you switch the
male versus the female
if these were autosomal traits?
Ory is shaking his head
no, and he's right, right?
In that case, it doesn't matter.
You can do the
reciprocal crosses,
you get the same result. But
because this is sex linked,
which one is the male and which
is the female is relevant.
And this actually
relates to something
that we just saw
on the MIT news.
I just got this
email this morning,
but it came out I
think yesterday,
which is that biology-related
research in the mechanical
engineering department--
specifically, the CAM lab--
they've been able to
design a 3D sort of model
for ALS disease, which is also
known as Lou Gehrig's disease.
And so what they've
done in the CAM lab
is to take cells from either
patients that have ALS
or from normal
individuals, and they coax
these cells to become neurons.
Here, you're seeing a neuron
in blue and green here.
And you see the neurites
extend from this neuron.
And they have a model
where this neuron can then
synapse with a muscle.
And so they're using this
3D sort of tissue model
to model ALS and to look
for drugs that might affect
ALS, potentially curing ALS.
And so last night, I
started reading about ALS
and was pleased to find
that there's actually
a very rare X-linked, dominant
form of the disease that
can be passed on from
generation to generation.
And the inheritance pattern of
this X-linked, dominant version
of ALS would have an
inheritance pattern
that's similar to what we
observe for the white mutant
in the fruit fly, right?
Whereas, if you have
an affected father,
and this is a dominant
mutant on the X chromosome,
then all of his daughters
will get that X chromosome
and be affected, whereas the
sons will all be unaffected.
However, if you have the
reciprocal situation,
where you have an affected
mother and an unaffected
father, then the
sons and daughters
get the disease randomly.
So this is a sort of form of
inheritance, which is relevant
if you're considering human
disease and some forms of it.
Most versions of ALS,
well, are sporadic,
but inherited forms are
usually autosomal dominant.
So this is a rare case here.
But I thought it was interesting
in that it's relevant to what
we've been talking about.
So now, just to recap--
here, I'll throw this
up so everything's up.
So in the last
lecture, we talked
about Mendelian inheritance.
And we talked about when
you take two parents that
differ in two traits
and you perform a cross,
you get a hybrid individual that
is heterozygous for both genes.
And now this is
the F1 individual.
Let's say we want to know
what types of gametes
this F1 individual produces.
We can perform a type of a cross
known as a test cross, where
we cross this individual
to another individual that
is homozygous recessive for
both these genes, which means
that you know
exactly which alleles
are coming from this parent.
And they're both recessive,
so you can see whether or not
the gamete produced
by this individual
has either the dominant
or the recessive allele.
Let me see.
I'll boost this up.
So now we can consider the
different types of progeny
that result from
this test cross.
And some will have the
two dominant alleles
from this parent
and will, therefore,
be heterozygous for
the A and B gene.
And it would exhibit the
dominant A and B phenotype.
I think that is what
I'm showing here.
So if the chromosomes,
during meiosis I,
align like this, then
the two dominant alleles
segregate together,
and you get AB gametes.
And you also, reciprocally,
get these lowercase a
and b gametes, as well.
So that's the other class here.
So you can get these
two classes of progeny.
And the phenotypes
of these two classes
will resemble the
parents, right?
So these are known
as parental gametes.
So these are the parentals.
But you know because
Mendel showed
that if you have genes
and their alleles
on separate chromosomes,
they can assert independently
of each other.
So an alternatively
likely scenario
is that the chromosomes
align like this,
where now the
dominant allele of B
is on the other
side of the spindle.
And therefore, these
chromosomes are
going to segregate like this
during the first meiotic
division.
And that gives rise
to gametes that
have a different combination
of alleles than the parents.
So you have some
that look like this.
So each of these would be
different classes of progeny.
And you have one last class
that would look like this.
And so neither of these look
like the original parents,
and so they're known
as non-parental.
And so if these two genes
are behaving according
to Mendel's second
law, where there's
independent assortment--
if you have
independent assortment,
what's going to be the ratio
of parental to non-parental?
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: One to one.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah,
Rachel says one to one,
and I think a number of
others also said one to one.
So you have 50% parental,
50% non-parental, right?
Because it's equally
likely to get
either of those alignments
of the homologous chromosomes
during meiosis I.
So now I'm going
to basically break
the rules I just explained
to you in the last lecture
and tell you about an exception,
which is known as linkage.
Gesundheit.
And in the abstract
sense, linkage
is simply when you
have two traits that
tend to be inherited together.
So just considering probability.
So you have traits
inherited together.
They're exhibiting what
is known as linkage.
But that's an abstract
way to think about it.
It's just based on
probability, right?
So a physical model
for what linkage is,
is that you have chromosomes.
The genes are on
the chromosomes.
And for two genes to
be linked, those genes
are physically near each
other on the chromosome.
So the physical model
is that two genes
are near each other
on the chromosome.
OK, so let's consider
again these generic genes,
A and B. If A and B
resulting from this cross--
if these two happen to be
on the same chromosome,
now they're physically
coupled to each other.
Then they're going to tend
to be inherited together.
No matter how these
align, they're
always going to
go together during
the first meiotic division.
And that's just going to only
give you the parental gametes.
So if there's linkage,
you're going to have--
let's consider the case where
you have complete linkage.
If you have complete
linkage, 100% of the gametes
are going to be
parentals, and you're
going to have 0% non-parental.
That's if the genes
are really, really,
really close to each
other, and maybe you
don't count so many progeny.
You won't see any
mixing between the two.
But there is a phenomenon
that can separate these genes,
and it's known as crossing over.
And another term to describe
it is recombination.
So the alleles are
getting recombined
between the chromosomes.
Recombination.
And what crossing over or
recombination is, is it's
a mixing of the
chromosomes, if you will.
Or it's an exchange of DNA.
So there's a physical
exchange of DNA from one
of the homologous
chromosomes to the other, OK?
So you can think of this
as an exchange of DNA
between the homologous
chromosomes, OK?
And that's important.
It's not an exchange between
the sister chromatids,
but between the
homologous chromosomes
that have the different alleles.
And what's shown here is
a micrograph showing you
a picture of the process
of crossing over.
You can see the centromeres
are the dark structures there.
And you can see how the
homologous chromosomes
intertwine.
And there are regions where
it looks like there's a cross.
Those are the homologous
chromosomes crossing over
and exchanging DNA such that
one part of that chromosome
gets attached to the
other centromere.
So I'll just show you in
sort of my silly cartoon form
how this is, just
to make it clear.
So let's say, again, you
have these A and B genes,
and they're physically
linked on the chromosome.
During crossing
over, you can get
an exchange of these alleles,
such as a bit of one chromosome
goes to the other homologous
chromosome and vice versa, OK?
So now you have the
dominant A allele
with the recessive b
allele and vice versa.
So now during meiosis I--
after meiosis II,
this will give rise
to two types of gametes, one
of which is non-parental.
And the same for
the one down here.
You get two types of gametes.
One is non-parental-- the
lowercase a, uppercase B
gamete.
So this happens if there's
incomplete linkage.
That means there can be a
recombination event that
separates the two genes.
And I'm going to give you
an example of a case where
data was collected with what
fraction of each class there
is.
So now we're
considering an example
where you have a linkage.
So A and B are on
the same chromosome.
And so we'll consider a
case where, in this class,
there are 165 members.
For this one, there is 191.
So I'm kind of--
line down like this.
And then for the first
recombinant class,
23 individuals.
And for the last, there
are 21 individuals.
So you can see there are many
more of the parental class
than the recombinant
class, but we
can calculate a frequency,
or recombination frequency,
between these two genes.
And in this case, the
recombination frequency
is 44/400, which is
equal to 11%, OK?
So 11% of the progeny
from this cross
had some sort of crossing over
between the A and B alleles.
It would've been up here.
Now, this frequency
is interesting,
because it is proportional
to the distance that
separates these two genes.
So this recombination
frequency is
proportional to the linear
distance along the chromosome
between the genes.
Now, it also depends on
the recombination frequency
in a given organism or in a
given part of the chromosome.
So when you're comparing
recombination frequencies
between different
organisms, there's
actually differences
in the real different--
they're not equivalent.
You can't compare
them, basically.
And also, there are
regions of the chromosome
where recombination happens
less frequently than others.
And so, again, you can't
compare distances along those.
But overall, you can use
this as a distance in order
to map genes along the
linear axis of a chromosome.
And maps are useful, because you
can see where stuff is, right?
So in this example here, I'll
highlight a couple of places.
Here's Rivendell.
Here's Lonely Mountain.
Here's Beorn's house.
So let's say we are
able to determine
the distance between
Rivendell and Lonely Mountain,
and the distance between Lonely
Mountain and Beorn's house,
and the distance between
Rivendell and Beorn's house.
You'd be able to get a
relative picture of where
all of these places are
in relation to each other.
So this is a two-dimensional
map I'm showing here.
It's not one dimensional,
but chromosomes
are one dimensional, so it's
a bit more accurate, OK?
So this idea that
recombination frequency can
be used to measure
distances between genes
and that this could be
used to generate a map
is an idea that an
undergraduate had
while working in Thomas Hunt
Morgan's lab back in 1911.
And what I find
fascinating about the story
is this guy basically
blew off his homework
to produce the first
genetic map in any organism.
So the person who did it
was Alfred Sturtevant,
and he was an
undergraduate at Columbia
working for Thomas Hunt Morgan.
And I'll just paraphrase
this quote here.
In 1911, he was talking
with his advisor, Morgan,
and he realized
that the variations
in the strength of linkage
attributed by Morgan
to differences in the
separation of genes--
so Morgan had already
made this connection,
that the recombination
frequency reflects
the distance between the genes.
But then Sturtevant
realized that this
offered the possibility
of determining sequences
in the linear dimension of the
chromosome between the genes,
OK?
So then-- this is
my favorite part--
"I went home and spent
most of the night,
to the neglect of my
undergraduate homework,
in producing the
first chromosome map."
And this is it.
So the first chromosome map was
of the Drosophila X chromosome,
which we've been talking about.
There's the white
gene, which we've
been talking about in
the context of eye color.
There's a yellow body gene here.
There's vermilion, miniature,
rudimentary, right?
These are all visible phenotypes
that you can see in the fly.
And you can measure
recombination
between various alleles
of these different genes.
All right, so now I want
to go through with you
an example of how you can make
one of these genetic maps.
And it's essentially
the same conceptually
as to what Sturtevant did.
And it involves what is
known as a three-point cross.
So a three-point cross.
So there are going to be
three genes, all of which
are going to be
hybrid, and I'll start
with the parental
generation that
is little a, capital
B, capital D.
And we'll cross
this fly or organism
to an organism that is capital
A, lower case b, lowercase d.
Yes, Carmen?
AUDIENCE: So when you
write the gametes up there,
does that imply that they
were analogous parents?
ADAM MARTIN: So what
I'm writing here
is the phenotype, basically.
And so these are homozygous
for each of these, yes.
I could also write this as--
but I'm not going to draw
the chromosomes, because it
kind of gets more confusing.
I'll draw the
chromosomes here in F1,
because we have now, basically,
a tri-hybrid with one
chromosome that looks
like this, right?
They got that chromosome
from this individual here.
And another chromosome
will look like this.
See?
So this F1 fly is heterozygous
for these three genes,
and it has these two
parental chromosomes.
So now we can look at the
gametes that result from this
fly by doing a test cross,
just like we did before.
And so we want to cross
this to a fly that's
homozygous recessive
for each of these genes.
And now we can look
at the progeny.
And just by looking
at the phenotype,
we're going to know the
genotype, because we
know all of the
flies from this cross
have a chromosome from
this individual that
has recessive alleles
for each gene.
So we can consider now
this first one here.
That's one potential
class of progeny.
Another class would be this one.
And these two, you can see,
resemble the parents, right?
So these are the parental
classes of the progeny.
So this is parental.
All right, now you can
consider all other combinations
of alleles.
And so I'll quickly
write them down.
You could have something--
progeny that look
like this and this.
These are just kind of
reciprocal from each other.
You could have progeny that
look like this and this.
And the last class
would be this and this.
So all of these progeny
that I drew down here
are recombinant,
because they don't
resemble the parents, right?
Because there are three
genes, now there's
many more ways to get
recombinant progeny, as opposed
to having just two genes, right?
So you can have many
different combinations
of these different alleles.
And so now I'm going
to give you data
from a cross with
three such genes.
So you might get
580 individuals that
look like this, 592 like this,
45 and 40, 89, 94, 3, and 5.
So this is data that is,
I believe, from fly genes.
I've just ignored
the fly nomenclature,
because it's confusing, and just
given them lettered names, OK?
But this reflects data
from some cross somewhere.
So now we want to know--
let's go back to our map.
We want to make a map, OK?
And so to make our
map, we're going
to want to consider
all pairwise distances
between different genes.
So we'll start with
the A and B gene.
I'll write over here.
So let's consider
the A/B distance.
And remember, to get
a distance, we're
looking at the number
of the frequency which
there is recombination
between these two genes, OK?
So we now have to look through
all of these recombinant class
of progeny and figure
out the ones that
have had a recombination
between A and B, right?
So on the parent chromosome,
you see little lowercase a
started out with capital
B and vice versa.
So any case where we
don't have lowercase
a paired with capital B, there's
been some type of exchange.
So here, lowercase
a's with lowercase b.
So that's a recombinant.
Here, uppercase A's
with uppercase B.
That's a recombinant, too.
So we have to add all these up.
So 45 plus 40.
How about here?
Recombination here or no?
Yes.
I'm hearing yes.
That's correct.
Here, recombination, yes or no?
Carmen's shaking her head no.
She's exactly right.
So we just have to-- these are
all the recombinants between A
and B. So it's 45
plus 40 plus 89
plus 94, which equals 268
over a total progeny of 1,448.
And that gives you a
map distance of 18.5%.
Because this method was
developed in Morgan's lab,
this measurement is also
known as a centimorgan.
It was named in honor of Morgan.
So that's what I refer to when
I have lowercase c capital
M. That's a centimorgan.
So you can also use
centimorgan here.
All right, so that's
A and B, but now we
have to consider
other distances.
So how about the A/D distance?
And again, we have to go
through and figure out
where the alleles for A and
D have been recombined, OK?
So little a is with
capital D, and upper case A
is with lowercase d.
So we have to find all the
cases where that's not the case.
Here, this is lowercase
a with capital D
and capital A with lowercase d.
This is parental from the
respect of just the A and D
genes, but all the rest of
these guys are recombinants, OK?
So this is 89 plus 94
plus 3 plus 5, which
comes out to be 191 over 1,448.
And this is 13.2 centimorgans.
So that's the distance between
A and D. Distance between A-B,
distance between A-D.
So the last combination,
then, is just B and D.
So if we consider
the B/D distance,
again, we have to look for
all cases in which lowercase
b and d become
separated and uppercase
B and D become separated.
Here, they're separated.
Wait, no, not here, sorry.
Here, they're not separated.
Here, they are separated.
Everyone see how I'm doing this?
Are there any
questions about it?
You can just shout it out
if you have a question?
So this distance is
6.4 centimorgans.
Everyone see how I'm considering
every pairwise combination
of genes and then just
ignoring the other one
and looking for
where there's been
a recombination in the progeny?
So now that we
have our distances,
we can make our map, right?
So the two genes that are
farthest apart are A and B, OK?
So that's kind of like here,
Rivendell and Lonely Mountain.
Those are the two genes
that are at the extremities.
So I'll draw this out.
It doesn't matter
which way you put it.
We're just mapping these
genes relative to each other.
But B and A are the farthest
apart from each other.
Now if we consider the
distance between B and D,
that's 6.4 centimorgans.
So it appears that
D is closer to B
than it is to A, because it's
13 centimorgans away from A, OK?
So D is kind of like
Beorn's house here.
It's closer to Rivendell than
it is from Lonely Mountain.
So we'll put that in there.
This distance is
6.4 centimorgans.
And then the distance
here is 13.2 centimorgans.
As far as I know, no one of
the field of genetic mapping
has been assaulted
by large spiders,
but the field is still young.
So one thing that should be
maybe bothering you right now
is if you add up the
distance between B and D
and D and A, you don't, in
fact, get 18.4 centimorgans.
Instead, you get
19.6 centimorgans.
This is 19.6 centimorgans.
So it seems like, somehow,
we are underestimating
this distance here, OK?
So we seem to be
underestimating this.
So why is it that we are
underestimating this distance?
Well, to consider that,
you have to sort of look
at how all of these
classes were generated.
So now I'm going to
go through each class,
and we'll look at
how it was generated.
I'm also going to--
well, I'll just draw
new chromosomes.
So we have to draw
this order now.
We have B, D, a.
So the first
chromosome is B, D, a.
That's right, B, D, a.
The other chromosome
is b, d, A. So now we
look and see how this
recombinant class was
generated.
So this is lowercase a.
We'll start with b-- lowercase
b, lowercase a, but capital D.
So it's capital D, lowercase a.
So that recombinant results
from this chromosome here, where
there's crossing over,
and little b gets
hooked up to big D and little a.
See how I did that?
And then if we
consider this class,
this is uppercase B, lowercase
d, capital A. So these two
classes of progeny result
from a single crossover
between B and D, OK?
So this is a single crossover
between B and D genes.
And now we can go through and
look at how this is generated.
So to get all recessive
alleles on the same chromosome,
there would be a crossover here.
And so this is a single
crossover between D and A.
So a single crossover
between D and A. Now,
these last couple
classes of progeny
are interesting in that they're
the least frequent class.
And so when we consider
how they're generated,
we'll start with uppercase B.
Let's see if I can
get rid of this.
So uppercase B,
lowercase d, lowercase a.
And so what this last class is,
is actually a double crossover.
So this is a double crossover.
And it's least frequent
because there's
a lower probability of getting
two crossovers in this region.
But now you see that
even though it doesn't
look like there was
recombination between A and D,
in fact, there was.
There were two
crossovers, and it just
looks like there was no
recombination, if you didn't
see the behavior of gene D.
So if we take into account
that there are actually
double crossovers
between B and A,
then if we add that
into our calculation
here, where you add in
3 plus 5 multiplied by 2
because these are both
double crossover events, then
you get the 19.6
centimorgans that you
would expect by adding up
the other recombinations, OK?
How is that?
Is that clear to everybody?
You're going to have to make
maps like this on the problem
set and possibly the test.
So make sure you can
given-- yeah, Ory?
AUDIENCE: I realized that
you immediately [INAUDIBLE]
overestimated the
difference between A and B
and not overestimated
B to D or D to A?
ADAM MARTIN: It's
because when you
have two genes that
are very far apart,
you can have
multiple crossovers.
And when you have
sort of crossovers
that are in pairs
of two, then it's
going to go from one
strand back to the other,
and so you're not going to see
a recombination between the two
alleles.
So it's an underestimate,
because if you have multiples
of two in terms of
crossovers, you're
going to miss the
recombination events.
You see what I mean?
You understand that you can miss
the double crossover events?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I get that.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah, right?
So then you're going
to underestimate
the number of crossovers
that actually happened
in that genetic region.
All right, now I want to end
with an experiment that, again,
makes the point that genes
are these entities that
are on chromosomes.
So just like you
can have linkage
between two genes on
the same chromosome,
you can also have
linkage between genes
and physical structures
on chromosomes,
like the centromere.
So you could have
genes like A and B
here that are present
on the chromosomes
and present very
near the centromere
of those chromosomes, OK?
So they could be right on
top of the centromere, OK?
And to show you how
this manifests itself,
I have to tell you about
another organism, which
is a unicellular
organism called yeast.
And yeast is special
and that it can
exist in both a haploid
and a diploid form.
So it has a lifecycle
that involves
it going both as a
haploid and as a diploid.
And so you can take yeast--
and we'll take two
haploid yeast cells.
And much like gametes, these
can fuse to form a zygote.
So, in this case, I'm taking--
again, we'll consider two
generic genes, A and B.
And we'll make a diploid yeast
cell that is heterozygous,
or hybrid, for A and B.
And what's great and
special about yeast
and why I'm telling you about
this is because as opposed
to flies and us and
other organisms,
the product of a
single meiosis is
packaged in this single
package, if you will.
So the yeast can
undergo meiosis,
and the product of
a single meiosis
is present in this case,
where each of these
would represent a haploid cell
that then can divide and make
many cells.
But this is the product of a
single meiosis in a package,
OK?
So you can actually
see the direct result
of a meiotic division, a
single meiotic division.
So this is the product of
a single meiotic division.
And that's special because
when we make gametes,
we have individual cells.
All the products of
meiosis are split up,
and then just one randomly
finds an egg and fertilizes it.
So you don't know
which of the gametes
are from the product
of a single meiosis.
And so being able to see the
product of a single meiosis
allows us to see
things like genes being
linked to physical
structures on the chromosome
like the centromere.
So if we consider this
case, these two genes
are both linked
to the centromere.
And during metaphor
phase of meiosis I,
they could align like
this, in which case
you would get spores
that are parental
for both dominant
alleles or parental
for both recessive alleles.
So each of these cells
is known as a spore.
So I'll label
spore numbers here.
So this is spore number.
And in this case,
you get two spores
that are dominant for both
alleles and two spores that
are recessive for both alleles.
Because there are two types,
it's known as a ditype.
And this is a parental ditype,
because you have two types
of spores .
And they are both parental
An alternative scenario
is that these chromosomes
would align differently, right?
So you get parental
spores there.
However, alternatively, you
could have this configuration,
where this is now flipped.
And during meiosis I here,
these chromosomes move together.
And they, again, produce
two types of spores,
so it's a ditype.
But in this case, all the
spores are non-parental.
So another scenario
is you get this.
And because there are two
types and they're non-parental,
this is known as
non-parental ditype.
That's a non-parental ditype.
And if these genes are linked
to the centromere completely,
then you can only get these
two classes of packages, OK?
So if these genes are unlinked--
so the two genes are
unlinked, but both
linked to the centromere,
then you get parental ditype--
50% parental ditype, type
50% non-parental ditype.
So I'm abbreviating
parental ditype PD
and non-parental ditype NPD.
So what has to happen to
get another type of spore?
And another type
of spore would be--
you could have spores that
are all different genotypes
from each other and that
you have A cap dominant A/B;
dominant A, recessive b;
recessive a, dominant B;
and lowercase a and b.
And this is known as tetratype,
because there are four types.
So how do you get
this tetratype?
Anyone have an idea?
Yeah, Jeremy?
AUDIENCE: You're crossing over.
So one of A and B would switch
in one of the [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Where would
the crossing over happen?
AUDIENCE: Between the two
[INAUDIBLE] one [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Between
the allele and what?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
ADAM MARTIN: The crossing over
would occur between the gene--
AUDIENCE: Oh, and
the centromere.
ADAM MARTIN: And the
centromere, exactly.
Jeremy is exactly right.
So Jeremy said that in
order to get a tetratype,
you have to have a
recombination event,
but this time, not
between two genes,
but between a gene
and the centromere.
So at least one of
the genes has to be
unlinked to the centromere.
And in that case, now
you get a meiotic event
that gives rise to four spores.
And there are four
different ways to get this.
So if you have two genes
unlinked and at least one
is unlinked to the
centromere, then you
get a pattern where
you have a 1 to 1
to 4 ratio between all
these different events.
So you have a 1 to 1 to 4
ratio between parental ditype,
non-parental ditype,
and tetratype.
And we can see this in yeast.
If you have two genes that
are linked to the centromere,
you only get parental ditypes
and non-parental ditypes,
where virtually everything
else gives rise to tetratypes,
except if they're linked.
What happens if
the two genes are
linked to each other,
irregardless of the centromere?
If you have two genes that are
linked, what's going to be--
what are your progeny
going to look like?
AUDIENCE: Parentals.
ADAM MARTIN: You're only
going to get the parentals,
or you're going to get
a lot of parentals.
Javier is exactly right, right?
If the two genes are
linked, the parental ditypes
are going to be much greater
than any of the other classes.
Now, this might seem
esoteric, but I like the idea
that you can have linkage
between a gene and something
that's just the place
on the chromosome that's
getting physically pulled.
It all makes it
much more physical,
which I think is
nice to think about.
All right, we're almost done.
I just have-- yes, Natalie?
AUDIENCE: Can you go over
what the PD [INAUDIBLE]??
ADAM MARTIN: Yes.
So PD is parental ditype.
So this is the parental ditype.
It's a class of
product here where
you get four spores that are
each of these genotypes, OK?
So each of these 1,
2, 3, and 4 would
represent one of these cells
from a single meiotic event.
Does that make sense, Natalie?
Does everyone see
what I did there?
So these 1 2 and 3 are the
spores of the meiotic event
right here.